welcome to this video playing
Emancipator Emancipator from the US its
place laughs okay the dreaded exchange
variation that are also have played
numerous times quits it too hmm I don't
see that too often after Bishop g4 they
usually play a 3-yard queen bee three
yep okay the queen is not particularly
well placed on the sea phone this is why
this is a bit unusual okay I don't want
to face 95 so just take this decide to
go for Bishop 36 it's a very healthy
structure so it's not going to castle
yeah okay with it okay castle guess what
long it's all very very creative
creative plate the exchange variation
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
white player is unambitious as we see
here he's some plate plate interesting
interesting chess after afterwards okay
I could take H to be really greedy yep
don't really see why I shouldn't so
let's gratz grab it Oh
I didn't think about that move okay I
need to evacuate my queen or is this
maybe I'm it's not really threatening to
drop it okay but that I want to I want
to have it back in my camp I like to
spend a move on that probably now look
age three and and back here so I want to
pawn but i'm not sure i want to i want
to cancel want to Castle short him I
probably can't keep the King under in
the center for a while it's not not
really necessary to Castle short it's
it's quite save on yet and I can try for
a bit of play myself I've also Knight e5
to see for
he has no own no direct way to open up
the center against my king so
I need to be not interesting so let's uh
I need I need to prepare the 1995 so
just King e7 connecting looks okay he's
covering a five there's still no opening
of the center so probably I can do here
can do this here prepare a five before
or before I immediately they are before
immediately is this good before all our
K is trying to get the night 33 and so
on B form a form
95 and this should be quite good 95
intending night c 4 so that she probably
needs to play be three and then I have
Roxy a to c 3 should be quite quite okay
yeah but what this is hanging yeah I
couldn't really move that so they are
okay just just back him
yeah this is just an attack end to two
extra pawns on top white resign yeah
probably just frustrated to take on a
six yeah I don't I don't really think
that giving away the the poll on h2
helps would probably just just this one
I mean to be honest I like black anyway
it's a very sound structure and it's
hard for him to to do anything with this
pawns I mean where are the porn breaks
here on the queenside it symmetrical
them there's nothing much happening and
he cannot easily play h4 h5 this is this
is blocked this is blocked so it's a
position where having nights some it's
usually a nice thing that I have two
nights I don't really need to Castle
short i can even if he in the game I had
a position where I had this H pawn it's
just a similar position like I should
adjust the age part is missing but I can
play in exactly the same manner even if
there is an H porn just kidding you 786
b5 and it's not quite clear what white
should do maybe you should try to to
play play for this after all it's very
difficult to accomplish but maybe you
should try try to open up the center
it's difficult because of the pressure
on those two points but its plan at
least alright thanks for watching